in this video we'll learn the first
things to do when you get an error this
is not throwing your laptop through the
window
let's say we want to use the question
answering pipeline on a particular model
and we get the following error
errors in python can appear overwhelming
because you get so much information
printed out but that's because python is
trying to help you the best it can to
solve your problem
in this video we'll see how to interpret
the raw report we get
the first thing to notice at the very
top is that python shows you with a
clear arrow the line of code that
triggers the error
so you don't have to fiddle with your
code and remove random lines to figure
out where the row comes from
you have the answer in front of you
right here
the arrows you see below are the parts
of the code python tried to execute
while running the instruction
here we are inside the pipeline function
and the error came on this line while
trying to execute the function check
tasks
which then raise the key error we see
displayed
note that python tells you exactly where
the function it's executing lives so if
you feel adventurous you can even go
inspect the source code
this whole thing is called the trace
pack
if you're running your code on collab
the traceback is automatically minimized
so you have to click to expand it
at the very end of the traceback you
finally get the actual error message
the first thing you should do when
encountering an error is to read that or
message
here it's telling us it doesn't know the
question answering task and name fully
gives us the list of supportist tasks
in which we can see that question
answering actually hits
looking more closely though we used an
underscore to separate the two words
when the task is written with a minus so
we should fix that
now let's retry our code with the tags
properly written
and what is happening today in a bar
error as we saw before we go look at the
bottom to read the actual error message
it's telling us that we should check our
model is a correct model identifier so
let's hop on to egf.co models
we can see our model listed there in the
ones available for question answering
the difference is that it's spelled
bert with one l and we used two
so let's fix that we finally get our
results
if your arrow is more complex you might
need to use a python debugger check out
the video is linked below to learn how
you